françois hollande président
social-démocrate revendiquée a donc
précisé la feuille de route pour la fin
de son quinquennat beaucoup y voient le
début le vrai début du quinquennat temps
les annonces tranche avec un discours
jusque-là dominant à gauche pour réagir
l'ancien ministre de nicolas sarkozy
bruno le maire bonsoir bonsoir hugo
lemaire qui ne s'interdit rien en vue de
la primaire ump en 2007 même nous sommes
là d'abord pour parler évidemment de la
conférence de presse de françois
hollande merci encore une fois d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp et dailymotion avec moi
tout à l'heure pour vous interroger
nadège peljak et perrine tarneaud alors
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment comme
beaucoup donc je le disais que cette
troisième conférence de presse de
françois hollande marquant en fait le
vrai début de son quinquennat
j'espère surtout que le troisième coup
sera le bon parce que les deux
précédents ont déçu je rappelle que
françois hollande nous avait annoncé la
mise en place d'une boîte à outils en
disant voilà tout est sur la table on va
avancer il s'est rien produit il nous
avait promis la baisse significative du
chômage en 2013 on a eu 100 milles de
demandeurs d'emploi supplémentaires nous
avait promis un choc de simplification
ya pas une entreprise qui a vu une
simplification dans sa vie quotidienne
donc le discours de françois hollande il
sonne agréablement aux oreilles moi je
dois dire que quand j'entends parler de
politique de l'offre de soutien aux
entreprises de simplification je suis
prêt à soutenir et à dire oui c'est la
bonne direction pour la france est la
seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est qu'on
trouve des solutions aux problèmes des
français notamment en particulier le
chômage dans ce mouvement vous et l'ue
et vous êtes prêt à suivre et françois
hollande je suis prêt à suivre tout ce
qui permettra réellement concrètement
rapidement de faire baisser le chômage
de masse en france alors vous diriez que
le président a changé on a changé de
président aujourd'hui mais j'aimerais
que ces décisions change est ici là
dessus que je suis plus sceptique parce
que je vois dans le discours de françois
hollande un certain nombre d'ambiguïtés
on nous dit par exemple nous allons
réduire massivement la dépense publique
puis d'un autre côté un supplément de 50
milliards supplémentaires d'un autre
côté on nous annonce déjà des dépenses
publiques supplémentaires 50000 emplois
aidés supplémentaires première
contradiction c'est l'heure où notre
dieu l'on croit pas à la version
l'accord du chômage est compris l'an
prochain c'est la preuve qu'il ya eu un
échec sur le chômage et que la politique
sociale d'accompagnement des chômeurs ne
suffit pas qu'il faut effectivement une
vraie politique économique différente
deuxième
fragilité dans le discours de françois
hollande il nous dit voilà je vais
alléger massivement les charges qui
pèsent sur les salaires petite remarque
au passage c'est ce que nous avions
commencé à faire il aurait peut-être
évité détruire ce qu'avait fait nicolas
sarkozy et de poursuivre la même
direction plutôt que de perdre 18 mois
dijoux m'a perdue dans un quinquennat
c'est non enfin admettons que ce soit la
bonne direction aucune explication sur
la manière dont on finance ses 36
milliards d'euros de cotisations
familiales difficiles j'ai surpris à
l'impôt économique a été prononcée dans
le mien mais 106 milliards devant les
l'éconavigation familiale 36 milliards
d'euros d'économies sur les prestations
familiales ma bon courage puis je suis
pas sûr que ce soit forcément la bonne
direction a besoin aussi d'une politique
familiale forte qu'on fasse des
économies oui qu'on supprime toutes les
aides la politique familiale non trois
fois non on a besoin d'une politique
familiale forte et dans le même temps il
nous dit il n'y aura aucune augmentation
d'impôts sur les ménages donc pas
d'augmentation de la tva donc pas
d'augmentation d'alsace et léger dont
acte alors comment on fait où est le
tour de passe passe comment est ce que
l'on arrive à trouver 36 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires sans transférer
la charge sur qui que ce soit là il ya
une explication qui doit être apportée
micro rapidement par le président de la
république parce que vraiment je n'y
crois pas je ne trouve pas ça
convaincant alors enfin troisième tour
et gêner alors pour les landes les
entreprises là il commence tout tableau
10e critique simplement parce que je
cite je suis devenu comme saint-thomas
c'est à dire que je ne juge qu aux actes
parce que j'ai été suffisamment déçu par
les précédentes interventions du
président république pour demander des
décisions et des actes il faut aller
vite la crise exige que nous allions
rapidement or quand on écoute
attentivement le présenter à un public
qui nous annonce un observatoire des
contreparties un conseil de
simplification des assises le fisc au
conseil du financement de la protection
sociale un conseil stratégique de la
dépense donc on multiplie les comités
théodule je suis pas sûr que ce soit un
gage de rapidité dans la décision ce
sont les trois réserves que j'aimais sur
ce choix fait par le président de la
république des contradictions des
ambiguïtés et la multiplication de
comités qui ne sont pas propices à la
rapidité de la décision donc vous doutez
encore des actes mais un calendrier
précis a été fixé qui nous mène jusqu'à
la fin du quinquennat encore ce que j'ai
entendu les décisions qui sont annoncées
vont dans le bon sens je veux simplement
qu'elles soient suivies d'effets et
françois hollande je le dis avec
beaucoup de gravité n'a pas le droit
cette fois-ci de décevoir les français
il faut qu'il aille vite il faut qu'il
aille fort il faut qu'il aille loin sans
quoi il n'y aura aucun effet sur la
situation économique des français aucun
effet sur leur situation personnelle sur
ces millions de personnes qui
aujourd'hui cherchent un emploi à temps
de trouver une place dans la société
hélas ce qui en résultera c'est une
colère profonde du peuple français et
c'est une victoire pour le medef puisque
pierre gattaz comme ses prédécesseurs
meilleur et réclamait de ne plus
financer la branche famille de la sécu
ce la viktwa adopte pour le medef pour
la cgpme la victoire louette pour les
français
la victoire sera pour les français le
jour nous passerons de 10 11 % de taux
de chômage en france qui est une plaie
pour la société française à un taux de
chômage de 5,6 ou au maximum 7 % comme
d'autres partenaires européens arrivent
très bien le faire notre voisin allemand
arrive à avoir un taux de chômage très
faible il arrive à voir des jeunes qui
trouvent facilement un emploi la france
a tous les atouts toutes les capacités
pour faire la même chose et je vais vous
dire même faire mieux que les allemands
et vous êtes prêt quand même demain à
voter pour ce pacte de responsabilité
si les ambiguïtés que vous évoquez sont
levés
escaladé la montagne avec le chef de
l'état comme le dit le patron dit m moi
je suis prêt à tout faire qui puisse
améliorer la situation des français et
je n'aurai pas de position partisanes je
ne crois pas que dans la situation où
nous sommes on puisse se permettre des
prises de position partisanes très bien
là vous répondait directement chef de
l'état puisqu'il a appelé l'opposition
aussi à à participer à ce grand
compromis social jamais proposé depuis
des 10 d'année at il précisé autre point
important la simplification toujours
pour faire des économies là des
collectivités locales alors avec des
régions en moins nous dit on et des
départements qui seraient rattachés aux
métropoles est-ce que ça également c'est
une piste que vous soutenez je ne peux
que la soutenir puisque c'est exactement
ce que nous avions commencé à proposer
avec la précédente majorité mais
pourquoi est ce que françois hollande at
il perdu plusieurs mois à défaire le
projet de conseiller territorial qui
allaient exactement dans ce sens
pourquoi est ce que dans ma région la
haute normandie je plaide depuis des
années pour la fusion de la haute et la
basse normandie pour avoir une seule
grande région normande et j'y crois
profondément j'aime la normandie je
pense qu'une seule normandie c'est plus
fort sa marque plus c'est plus efficace
qui s'est systématiquement opposé la
majorité socialiste au conseil régional
qui est systématiquement dit non donc je
me réjouis de cette prise de conscience
mais mesurons bien quand même que c'est
un revirement complet dans la politique
constante des socialistes qui ont
multiplié les communautés locales temps
multiplié les échelons locaux et qui
n'ont pas voulu jusqu'à présent et
réduire ce nombre d'échelons locaux
enfin ça c'est jesse harris tic de tous
les camps politiques à reconnaissait la
décence dans la bonne direction
corporative en mai mais la très
franchement on est à l'opposé de ce qui
avait été défendue notamment dans les
régions je cite l'exemple normand mots
pour inciter d'autres par la majorité
sociale donc ça vient d'un virage
françois
simplement qu'ils soient suivies
d'effets et notamment pour les
collectivités locales allons plus loin
que l'on nous donne le nombre de régions
que l'on peut parvenir je pense que dix
ou onze régions ce serait un bon chiffre
est ce que véritablement françois
hollande va jusqu'à la fusion des
départements et les régions comme à
l'ump nous le proposons je pense que
c'est jusque là qu'il faut aller s'il va
aussi loin tant mieux mais surtout qui
ne s'arrête pas en chemin des demi
mesures seront pires que tout est ce que
justement il a la majorité nécessaire
pour ne pas s'arrêter au milieu du
chemin selon vous il s'est dit assuré
d'avoir le soutien de sa majorité
présidentielle nous verrons c'est à lui
comme chef de l'état de trouver une
majorité derrière lui je comprends tout
de même qu'il puisse y avoir
déception dans sa majorité devant le
reniement complet du chef de l'état je
rappelle que françois hollande candidat
a été élu sur un programme
révolutionnaire taxer les riches à 75%
politique de la demande création de
soixante mille emplois publics
supplémentaires dans l'éducation
nationale
augmentation massive des impôts sur les
français surtout les français surtout
les impôts et puis quelques mois après
il revient dit attendez moi je veux une
politique de l'offre je suis social
démocrate donc on va oublier tout ce que
j'ai fait on efface la tablette et l'eau
repart à zéro il ya cool quoi perturber
sérieusement sa majorité
jean luc mélenchon appelle d'ailleurs
les élus verts et quitter immédiatement
le gouvernement vous pensez que la
majorité pourra continuer ainsi ce sera
une nouvelle ligne d'horizon les élus
verts a déjà avalé tellement de couleurs
qu une couleuvre de plus je pense pas
que ce soit ça qui les amène à renoncer
à leur poste ministériel je vous
rappelle quand même que le chef de
l'état a précisé que le discours du
bourget restait ça sa référence ans se
souvient de ce qu'il avait dit c'est
d'ailleurs il a essayé sur le négociant
jeudi je ne jugerai qu'aux actes parce
que c'est compliqué d'aller défendre la
continuité quand visiblement il y a
rupture c'est compliqué d'aller
expliquer je suis dans la ligne du
discours du bourget alors que
visiblement il est en train d'amorcer un
tournant totalement différent et je
souhaite qu'il poursuive sa
clarification qui laisse jusqu'au bout
son chemin de damas pour faire clair il
a vu que il était dans le mur il a vu
que sa politique ne menait nulle part il
a vu qu'il était en situation d'échec
sur le sujet de préoccupation majeure
des français qui est l'emploi il accepte
de faire un tournant qu'il aille au bout
de ce choix est-ce qu'on peut
légitimement s'interroger sur les
dangers d'une politique qui serait en
fait une super rigueur ce à quoi peut
mener tout ce qui est annoncé en matière
d'économies budgétaires bono le maire
moi j'ai jamais compris je vais vous
dire ce débat sur la rigueur parce que
la rigueur c'est maintenant à la rigueur
pour les français que je rencontre
partout dans mes déplacements c'est
maintenant les salariés les plus
modestes qui ont tout juste le smic et
qui sont accablés de charge d'impôts de
taxes d'habitation de divers
prélèvements qui arrivent pas boucler la
fin des mois alors même qu' ils sont
salariés mais c'est déjà la rigueur pour
eux donc ce qui n'est pas la rigueur
c'est ce qui permet de créer des emplois
et donner une place à chacun dans la
société française c'est ça qui la vraie
lutte contre la rig en tous les cas vous
n'êtes pas suivi bruno le maire sur un
point le chef de l'état a précisé qu'il
n'était pas question de renier les les
allocations qui sont versées aux
chômeurs surtout dans cette période très
difficile alors vous vous prenez des
mesures radicales il y a aussi dans les
propositions du chef de l'état des
manques criants quand on parle de
simplification
j'ai rien entendu sur le droit du
travail je n'ai rien entendu sur le
contrat de travail je n'ai rien entendu
sur les seuils sociaux qui touchent les
pme qui empêche les pme de grandir ce
camp et a dit aux salariés d'être fait
tout pour paris le havre et caen est à
49 salariés ont un aspect qu'on pourra y
campe un camp complètement un nom mais
ça veut dire qu'il ya un peu sur votre
terrain savez français encore un effort
comme le disait l'écrivain et bien
françois hollande encore un effort en
tous les cas il a annoncé des
initiatives pour faire converger sur le
plan économique
et social la france et l'allemagne ça
c'est un point positif que voulait
souligner qu'elle reprend le travail qui
avait été engagé par nicolas sarkozy a
encore et que j'avais moi même mis en
place comme ministre des affaires
européennes c'est à dire la convergence
sociale la convergence fiscale avec
l'allemagne c'est évident que dans une
zone euro nous avons la même monnaie que
l'allemagne c'est mieux d'avoir un impôt
sur les sociétés qui soit proche c'est
mieux d'avoir un salaire minimum qui
soit proche d'être plus animée
aujourd'hui avec la grande coalition
allemande je pense que les fondamentaux
allemands n'ont pas beaucoup bougé avec
la grande coalition contrairement à ce
que j'entends ici ou là les allemands
ont une ligne économique une ligne
social qui reste la même de façon très
inconstante ya les petits et justement
bien entendu mais c'est une ligne qui
reste constante alors m rapprocher nos
modèles tendu à vous écouter malgré les
ambiguïtés que vous soulignez bien peut
quand même se demander si françois
hollande n'a pas coupé l'herbe sous le
pied de l'opposition à
vous l'avez dit vous pouvez pour
certaines mesures avant d'accueillir sur
ce thème là nadège paul jacques de l'
agence france-presse les explications de
sandra cerqueira
si on ferme les yeux en écoutant le
président on pourrait croire à un leader
de droite il nous faut produire plus il
nous faut produire mieux
c'est donc sur l'offre qu'il faut agir
sur l'offre depuis le début de l'année
françois hollande a décidé de surprendre
avec son discours social démocrate voire
sociale libérale moins de charges pour
les entreprises moins de dépense
publique et moins d'impôts une rupture
sémantique loin de la tradition
socialiste avec son pacte de
responsabilité
le président coupe l'herbe sous le pieds
de l'adversaire
cette stratégie de françois hollande est
cette politique de l'offre elle vient un
peu empiéter sur les plates-bandes
économique d'une certaine droite il
fragilise aussi la capacité de l'ump
notamment et de la droite parlementaire
en général à proposer autre chose
compliquée pour la droite de trouver
comment riposter le programme économique
de françois hollande fait penser à celui
de l'ump acté lors d'un séminaire en
novembre dernier et le fait que la
droite soit embarrassé prouve qu'elle
n'est pas très claire elle même dans sa
tête et qu'elle ne sait pas ni ce
qu'elle veut ni avec quel chef c'est le
signe l'embarras de la droite de ses
propres difficultés
bien davantage que d'un changement de
cap de françois hollande
déstabiliser enfin l'opposition voilà
qui redonne le sourire aux socialistes
ce qui compte c'est de redresser le pays
si en plus la politique menée par
françois hollande sème la zizanie à
droite crée un malaise à droite on ne va
pas s'en plaindre
voilà l'ump face à un problème
stratégique approuvé dans la foulée du
medef le cap de françois hollande ou
rester dans l'habituel opposition au
risque de paraître caricatural
voilà avec nous l'année jacques de l'
agence france-presse
alors on vient d'entendre monsieur
bailly qui disent ah bah écoutez ici ça
sème la zizanie a droit qu on va pas
s'en plaindre - vous écoutons je peux eu
l'impression d'une zizanie puisque vous
avez dit je reprends les mots le
discours de monsieur hollande sonne
agréablement et je suis prêt à le
soutenir si ça marche évidemment on
n'est pas dans la zizanie là qu'est ce
que vous répondez monsieur valley
raisons d'avoir la moindre zizanie je
vais décevoir monsieur vallini qui
l'approchent un peu politicienne du
sujet moi ça m'intéresse pas la
politicaillerie seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est les solutions qu'on
apporte aux français nous défendons à
l'ump il je défends depuis plusieurs
années une politique de l'offre la
restauration de la capacité de
production de la france le soutien aux
entreprises qui sont les seuls à pourra
créer des emplois notamment nos pme nos
petites entreprises aux artisans nos
commerçants le président la république
nous dit je vais avancer dans cette
direction mais soyons cohérents peu de
cohérence en politique ça fera pas de
mal à partir du moment où c'est son cas
pousser sa direction et que c'est ce que
défend l'ump depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant puisque c'est de la ligne qui
était adopté que c'est la ligne que je
défends personnellement depuis
maintenant plusieurs années jeudi
essayons d'avancer et s'il présente dans
la public a le courage de prendre
effectivement ses décisions
effectivement voilà si sabine la
situation du pays je dis tant mieux
alors il parle d'offres le président
elle en a pas d'offre parle de
production exactement comme vous
exactement d'ailleurs
jean françois copé qui parle également
d'offres qui parle de production la
france doit devenir un petit producteur
on l'a souvent entendu dire ça mais
comme vous disiez tout à l'heure michel
est ce que vous êtes en train de vous
faire couper leur son pied quel va être
votre marge à vous parce que je
comprends bien vous avez envie que
hollande réussi ce que monsieur hollande
réussi ce que les socialistes russe
enfin on va pas quand même se raconter
des histoires vous avez vraiment envie
que les socialistes réussissent bas et
vous alors vous voudriez bien revenir au
pouvoir ont dit c'est que si les
socialistes réussi souviendrai pailleret
c1 qui resteront nous sommes pour
l'instant dans le discours pas encore
dans les décisions et je crois que nous
avons un certain nombre de choses a dit
françois hollande la première c'est que
les décisions doivent être en accord
avec les paroles or ce n'est pas le cas
il dit par exemple produit plus et
produire mieux nous avons aujourd'hui vu
l'adoption de la loi sur l'agriculture à
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture qui précisément ne permet pas de
produire
à ce texte parce qu'il ne permet pas de
produire plus ne donne pas justement les
éléments de compétitivité nécessaire à
nos agriculteurs pour produire plus dont
contradiction si vraiment françois
hollande est cohérent avec lui-même
qu'il dise voilà j'ai fait mon
aggiornamento dont je retire de textes
sur l'agriculture parce qu'il faut
produire plus et produire mieux que ce
texte ne permet pas deuxième chose comme
je le rappelais précédemment il y a des
manques dans ce discours de françois
hollande le droit du travail qui est un
point clé pour les entreprises ne paraît
un manque important dans le discours du
président de la république nous avons
besoin d'un droit du travail plus simple
plus souple pour embaucher au moins
ducret ciblant les entreprises
contraintes sur les entreprises et la
jeunesse a aussi la responsabilité faut
quand même rendre grâce au président
hollande c'est ce qu'il a dit des
responsabilités ça fait partie du deal a
créé des emplois presse je n'ai pas
entendu parler de droit du travail de
contrat de travail alors que c'est pour
moi à démontrer oui mais c'est encore
ambigu c'est encore un peu flou ça
manque encore un peu de précision et ses
salons fantasy social ça fera l'objet de
discussions oui mais qu'est ce qui va
arriver à un compromis il compte sur
vous d'ailleurs au bout j'espère que la
montagne accouchera vraiment de réformes
substantielles et pas d'une souris alors
que si la montagne de cette conférence
de presse accouche d'une souris c'est à
dire de petites décisions techniques
alors que c'est un vrai changement de
modèle français qu'il faut engager c'est
ça que je défends un changement de
modèle français avec des équilibres qui
soit plus stable avec un vrai soutien
aux entreprises avec une redéfinition de
la place de l'état et du rôle de l'état
avec plus de créations de richesses et
sans doute moindre distribution là si on
va vraiment
je n'ai encore rien entendu de la part
du président de la république mais si
déjà il ya un premier pas dans la bonne
direction de tant mieux mais attention à
ce que la montagne n'accouche pas d'une
souris parce que la déception sera cruel
chez les français vous renvoie cet
argument d'une certaine façon françois
hollande puisque là quand on lui demande
à quelle est la différence entre nicolas
sarkozy et lui répond mais ce qu'il pas
fait
oui j'ai pas très bien saisi ce que je
voulais dire françois hollande par là
parce que nicolas sarkozy a fait des
choses a fait avant c'est justement en
matière de style aérien tous les
chiffres de la détérioration budgétaire
économique
du discours un peu facile tourner dans
le passé moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
l'avenir et il en face de la lune
en face de lui une opposition qui a je
crois une réponse constructive quand
j'entends les réactions des uns et des
autres parce qu'ils en face de lui une
opposition qui pense d'abord aux
intérêts de la france et des français
mais ça veut dire aussi des jeux de plus
jacques pour l'opposition pour la
famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens l'ump c'est bien la preuve
aussi qu'il faut que nous élargissions
le champ de nos propositions aux
français il s'agira pas de proposer aux
français uniquement des réformes
économiques des réformes sociales et la
réduction des déficits ce sera
totalement insuffisante alors que ce
sera quoi mais la droite doit aussi
parler d'éducation elle doit aussi
expliqué que si nous voulons vraiment
votre politique de l'offre qui marche il
faut aussi que nous formions mieux nos
jeunes il faut aussi que l'alternance
développe que la formation les
qualifications augmentent il faut aussi
que nous ayons un système éducatif qui
prépare au mieux nos jeunes à l'emploi
il faut que la droite et les
propositions sur sa conception de la
nation son ambition d'après ce que j'ai
compris à la droite de justement faire
ce genre de proposition a largué le
conseil national du valais 5 jeux qui
portera que sur les questions
économiques et sociales à nous d'ouvrir
le champ de nos propositions pour avoir
à proposer aux français pas simplement
des changements économiques et sociaux
mais une conception de la nation une
idée de l'éducation si vous étiez au
pouvoir lui feriez mieux européenne une
conception aussi de la démocratie vous
savez que cette un thème sur lequel je
me bats de manière un peu isolé je le
reconnais mais les troubles grossistes
petit à petit depuis des mois et des
mois pour que ce changement soit
efficace il faut aussi qu'il y ait un
changement dans notre démocratie il faut
aussi qu'il ya un changement chez les
politiques regardez cette défiance
totale dont les français font preuve
hardelot responsables politiques et de
la politique en général moi je n'ai vu
aucune proposition de la part de
françois hollande sur ce sujet la
réforme des institutions
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
l'obligation des missions des
fonctionnaires quand ils deviennent
député ou sénateur toutes les
propositions contenues depuis des mois
et peut-être qu'elle était une
conférence de presse il y aura aussi
cette prise en compte la crise
démocratique que traverse notre pays
parce qu'il y à crise démocratique et si
on veut vraiment obtenir des résultats
sur le champ économique sur le champ
politique il faut aussi que l'on
répondre à cette crise de la démocratie
française alors justement on en vient
aux grandes mesures que l'ump va
soumettre à son conseil national le 25
janvier pour l'instant ce sont des
mesures économiques et sociales c'est ce
qu'elle a dit l'ump sont pas encore elle
vous avancer pas à pas bon alors il ya
notamment la suppression des 35 heures
on en parle depuis longtemps de cette
suppression apparemment maintenant ça
devrait se faire enfin si vous si vous
arrivez au pouvoir
voilà la vraie situation de monsieur
loeb a parfaitement marché et puis moi
enfin on n'en est pas là alors en tous
les cas on imagine mal les salariés
acceptent de travailler 39 heures payées
35 alors qu'est ce que c'est quoi le
truc vous un comprend pas il ya encore
là aussi dans le travail que nous avons
à faire un l'ump c'est un travail
progressif moi je me félicite de ce qui
a été fait autour de jean-françois copé
au cours du dernier séminaire de travail
parce qu'on a progressé et on a
aujourd'hui en matière économique et
sociale un cap qui je crois rassemble
une large majorité des membres de l'ump
et puis il ya des choses que nous devons
encore tranché moi je ne suis pas
favorable à 39 heures payées 35
c'est important que les salariés soient
bien rémunérés c'est important que le
travail soit bien rémunérés c'est
important que tous ceux qui travaillent
vivent correctement la fin du mois et
c'est une des choses qui aujourd'hui
pose tant de problèmes en france ceux
qui travaillent vivent parfois moins
bien que ceux qui ne travaillent pas
parce que quand vous partez le matin
comme prenez votre voiture qu'il faut
payer l'essence qu'il faut revenir chez
je crois qu'il faut payer la garde
d'enfants et qu'au bout du compte vous
gagnez 1240 euros par mois ben vous vous
en sortez pas c'est ça la réalité et il
n'est pas normal n'est pas juste que
celui qui travaille de cette façon
puisse vivre moins bien que celui qui
vit des revenus de redistribution
s'ajoutent chose mais ma question porte
avion comment on fait fonds soit
retravaillé propres
sans coûter trop cher à l'état parce que
aux entreprises tout ça veut dire que on
gagne aussi si on travaille 39 eur et
puis
l objet de débats entre nous à
poursuivre ses débats je crois que c'est
important si on veut vraiment avoir un
projet de l'ump qui soit crédible qui
soit solide comprennent aussi un peu de
temps on a posé une première brique avec
ce projet économique sur lequel nous
avons un très large accord une fois
encore je me félicite de l'esprit dans
laquelle ça s'est construit il faudra
détails et ça il faudra surtout élargir
nos propositions renouveler notre
conception de la politique renouvelé
notre pratique politique renouvelé notre
conception de la société française
regardez la position que j'ai prise sur
le mariage pour tous je me suis abstenu
bien je tiens cette position car je
pense que c'est important d'adresser ce
message à tous les français que à l'ump
certains considèrent que effectivement
il y avait besoin de protection
supplémentaire pour les couples
homosexuels le texte de loi ne me
satisfaisait pas
satisfaisait pas non plus de claquer la
porte en disant non à tout il faut
surtout les sujets doit être capable
accord d'apporter une offre totalement
nouvelle et intense et trois sourires ce
nouveau modèle français j'en ai le mien
dans deux mois on a des élections
municipales un ce que vous nous dites là
c'est à l'horizon 2017 nathan voit la
fin mars on a les municipales vous êtes
optimiste paris marseille marseille on a
vu d'ailleurs comme monsieur gaudin
était soutenu par force ouvrière c'est
un peu original ce qu'est toulouse vous
voyez que toutes les lignes politiques
sont en train de voler en éclats sous
nos yeux nationalement et localement oui
la question c'est est-ce que vous êtes
optimiste que vous croyez volontariste
je me déplace énormément en face et je
vais moi je vais voir les candidats et
je crois que nous aurons beaucoup de
bonnes surprises dans ce qui est pour
moi l'essentiel les villes moyennes sur
les grandes villes je pense que nathalie
kosciusko morizet gagnera paris parce
que c'est une excellente candidate et
qu'elle créera la surprise aujourd'hui
les challengers mais choquel mais une
bonne campagne elle est courageuse elle
est résolue elle est déterminée ça
portera ses fruits les électeurs de
paris se laisseront pas dicter leur
victoire dicter leur candidat et sur les
villes moyennes je vois partout je suis
allé à saint-etienne on a un très bon
candidat on peut voir
c'est quand même
un énorme défaut en politique c'est
celui de la cohérence je défends les
mêmes idées depuis des années en matière
économique j'ai la même conception de la
nation j'ai une conception la société
française qui essayent de s'ouvrir aussi
un certain nombre de différences bien
cette cohérence elle m'amène à penser
que quand on est membre de l'ump on ne
soutient pas un candidat qui a voté pour
françois hollande françois bayrou a voté
pour françois hollande c'est son choix
il est libre je respecte ce choix mais
moi comme membre de l'ump effectivement
je ne soutiens pas françois bayrou à pau
et j'espère que notre famille politique
mais notre famille politique peut
construire à pau et dans le béarn de
manière générale une autre offre
différente voilà voilà cette imposition
à s'isoler sur wii zapper et changer la
durée sur le noter j'ai vu aussi que
parfois par exemple sur leurs fonds
d'indemnisation du chômage eh bien on en
a marre en compte les gens vous
rejoignent alors une petite question
encore sur françois hollande il a il n'a
pas apporté le soutien de la france à
michel barnier qui est candidat à la
succession de josé manuel barroso
moi j'aurais voulu le soutien france
parce qu'un seul barnier est aujourd'hui
le seul en france à pouvoir devenir
président de la commission européenne
c'est un poste très important pour notre
avenir national et notre avenir européen
moi je soutiens michel barnier je pense
que ça aurait été bien qu' il y ait un
consensus national autour de la personne
de michel barnier comme candidat à la
présidence de la commission européenne
merci nadège perrine tarneaud arrive
maintenant donc
avant cela on va voir quand même hein
comment françois hollande s'est sortie
toujours brièvement et fermement des
questions sur sa vie privée mounir souci
la question brûlait toutes les lèvres et
elle a été posée en premier la vie
privée du président a ouvert le jeu des
questions réponses le regard sombre
françois hollande s'est prêté à
l'exercice
chacun
dans sa vie personnelle peut traverser
des épreuves
c'est notre cas
ce soit des moments douloureux une
réponse pour évacuer le sujet mais il
est revenu au cours des échanges à
chaque assaut des journalistes le
président répliqué de manière courtoise
mais toujours sèche comme sur cette
question à propos de la santé de valérie
trierweiler
elle se repose je n'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire accusé par
l'opposition d'abaisser la fonction
présidentielle françois hollande a tenté
de ramener le débat sur la question des
libertés liberté de la vie privée mais
aussi liberté de la presse qu'il refuse
de poursuivre mais mon indignation est
totale je dis bien totale et là dessus
il s'agit d'une question qui n'est pas
personnel pas seulement personnel même
si je suis dans la responsabilité que
vous savez le président a annoncé le
prochain épisode du feuilleton en
précisant qu'il clarifierait sa
situation personnelle avant son
déplacement aux états unis le mois
prochain
question donc sur cette délicate
question de la vie intime du chef de
l'état arnaud lemaire maire ou bien de
l'entendre françois hollande a refusé de
parler de sa vie privée vous comprenez
sa décision sa position je pense que
c'est bien que cette conférence de
presse et été
consacrée très largement presque
exclusivement aux questions économiques
et sociales n'empêche parce que les
français attendaient des réponses sur ce
sujet là je pense qu'il est nécessaire
aussi que françois hollande fournisse
des explications donc il a annoncé qu'il
fournirait ses explications dans un
autre cadre ils nous attendent
je crois que c'est bien de dissocier les
deux mais ça veut dire que l'engagement
a été pris auprès des français
d'apporter des explications nous
attendons maintenant
à la mi février que le point de
divergence que j'ai avec lui c'est quand
il nous explique que ce n'est que du
ressort de la vie privée non c'est un
impact public valérie trierweiler est à
l'elysée elle a des collaborateurs elle
est dans des fonctions qui l'amène à
dépendre aussi de biens publics donc à
partir de ce moment là il est légitime
que les français posent des questions et
qu'on leur apporte des réponses est ce
que vous êtes de ceux qui remettent en
cause aujourd'hui comme l'a fait par
exemple françois rebsamen le patron à
des sénateurs socialistes ce matin le
statut qui n'existe pas réellement en
france de première dame est-ce qu'il
faut supprimer est-ce que c'est
complètement obsolète suranné
le première dame en france elle n'a pas
de statut c'est à dire que rien n'est
défini par les textes c'est plus une
jurisprudence un comportement un choix
que fait le président de la république
moi je veux dire définir le meilleur
choix c'est que le président de la
république soit président de la
république et que sa femme ou sa
compagne reste la plus discrète possible
la plus à l'écart de la vie publique est
ce que c'est possible je pense que c'est
possible j'ai eu le choix qui est fait
dans d'autres grandes démocraties c'est
le cas en allemagne c'est le cas aussi
en grande bretagne où les épouses les
compagnes et compagnons occupe un rôle
beaucoup moins important il ya quelque
chose d'un peu désuet même je vais vous
dire dans cette expression première dame
de france pour moi il n'y a pas de
première dame de france toutes les dames
de france sont à égalité
ça veut dire que cette dame la compagnie
la la dépose du chef de l'état ne doit
même pas voir un bureau des
collaborateurs à l'elysée donc c'est ça
l'idée je ne vois pas la même chose que
je dis très simplement avec beaucoup
d'humilité parce que j'ai pas la
prétention d'avoir la vérité révélée sur
un sujet aussi sensible les français
élisent un président la république qui a
une fonction éminente qui doit leur
apporter des réponses sur tous les
sujets fondamentaux de leur vie
quotidienne de leur avenir national il a
une épouse il a une compagne il vit avec
quelqu'un très bien moi je n'aime pas
cette expression de première dame de
france je trouve qu'elle a quelque chose
de désuet je trouve quelque chose de
dépassé et qu'elle fait peser sur les
épaules de cette femme une
responsabilité qu'elle n'a pas forcément
choisi est ce que le chef de l'état en
revanche une vie privée on a entendu
françois hollande lors sa conférence de
presse aujourd'hui s'indigner sur les
révélations sur sa vie privée mais
est-ce que à l'heure des réseaux sociaux
à l'heure de la transparence le chef de
l'état français peut encore avoir une
véritable vie privée est un peu
d'hypocrisie dans cette idée que le
président de la république ils puissent
avoir une vie privée clairement défini
le canton était du président de la
république c'est pour un mandat de cinq
ans on se doit aux français que notre
matin à votre vie de nous apparaît à ce
moment là notre vie par définition ne
vous appartient plus l'eau il a été
léger jeunes ans je vais pas de
reproches de ce type là je dis
simplement parce que quand même été
imprudent au moment où je dis ça il
voulait relancer
et privés qui ne regarderait absolument
pas des français pour le président de la
république lui-même ça me paraît
difficile qu'on protège certains aspects
de sa vie privée je pense aux enfants
par exemple ils sont pas concernés ils
n'ont pas fait ce choix c'est lui seul
qui a fait ce choix de devenir présents
dans le public c'est un choix éminemment
respectable mais je ne vois pas en quoi
ses enfants son épouse sa campagne
pourraient eux être directement associés
à ce choix c'est ça pour moi l'année
vous rêvez distribué en revanche tous
les choix
publics s'engagent personnellement il
faut avoir une discipline de fer habiter
un peu plus la fonction comme a pu le
dire jean luc mélenchon n'importe quel
niveau de la vie politique je pense
qu'il faut de discipline de fer avait
été simplement d'un modeste députés
avait soumis vous même à la tentation de
la pipolisation par des propositions je
ne sais pas d'organe de presse ou alors
vous mettez tout dans la littérature
nous demande toujours aux gens
en france toujours gelé un moment où
vous dis mais qui vous êtes c'est quoi
votre vie les chemins
il ya des limites à fixer mais c'est
très difficile parce que c'est légitime
aussi que les français dont vous
solliciter les suffrages ou leur disiez
voilà je m'appelle bono le maire j'ai 44
ans je suis marié depuis maintenant près
de seize ans j'ai quatre garçons voilà
c'est légitime qu'on sache à c'est
transparent j'aimais absolument
la frontière devient difficile est
ce que on met en avant son épouse sa
compagne ou est-ce qu'on ne le fait pas
c'est des choix qui sont très
personnelles mais un homme public c'est
quand même compliqué à ce niveau là
d'aller dire respecter ma vie privée
c'est difficile est ce que vous avez dit
l'impression quand même que d'une façon
générale
françois hollande a mal anticipé les
évolutions importés par le quinquennat
dans nos institutions dans leur pratique
je pense qu'un certain nombre de choses
qui effectivement il n'a pas forcément
vu venir
la séparation vie publique vie privée
elle est devenue de frontières très
ténue pas forcément quelque chose que il
a compris à présent la république ne
s'appartient pas il appartient au peuple
français il doit être protégé en
permanence sa sécurité doté de garantir
en permanence je suis pas sûr qu'il ait
toujours eu conscience de cela le
quinquennat veut dire que les choses
vont très vite et que dès le premier
jour du quinquennat on doit être
efficace
on doit être utile pour les français or
qu'est-ce que monde cette conférence de
presse finalement c'est que françois
hollande n'était pas prêt et que c'est
les français qui en ont fait les frais
comme pendant 18 mois nous avons perdu
du temps essayé de solutions pu essayer
une autre à tergiverser à hésiter à
reculer à dire je fais ceci et puis je
défais cela souvenez-vous parce qu'on a
la mémoire courte du nombre de décisions
que françois hollande a pris au début de
son quinquennat qui ont été supprimés
par la suite ses propres décisions
que de temps perdu que de temps perdu
sur le dos des français bruno le maire
je voulais vous faire rire une enquête
parue hier du cevipof sur la défiance
envers les politiques qui atteint
maintenant des niveaux relevés au niveau
assez lui sinon même a pu dire le
politologue pascal perrineau à tel point
que 50 % des pères des personnes
interrogées sont pour une démocratie de
type bonapartiste c'est à dire un homme
fort qui ne se préoccupe ni du parlement
ni des élections est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à être cet homme là qui fait un
homme fort ou une femme forte j'en suis
totalement artistes et mon intuition
mais pourquoi ça m'inspire simplement
que cette révolution démocratique que
j'appelle de mes voeux et que certains
critiques dans ma propre famille
politique est devenue une urgence
absolue il faut changer les
fonctionnement institutionnel les
fonctionnement démocratique français
quand j'étais tout à l'heure aux
questions d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale
577 députés mais mon dieu qu'est ce
qu'on fait que 577 députés on a augmenté
le nombre de députés à l'assemblée
nationale dans le même temps aux
demandes et aux entreprises d'avoir
moins de salariés aux administrations
d'avoir moins de fonctionnaires aux
services déconcentrés les plus efficaces
mais c'est inacceptable c'est
intolérable il est urgent que nous
passions de 577 à au maximum 400 députés
consacrée exclusivement la fonction de
député et rien d'autre comment est-ce
qu'on peut accepter dans notre
démocratie dans notre république qui
devrait être exemplaire au nom des
idéaux de 1789 que les hauts
fonctionnaires puissent garder tous
leurs privilèges aux fonctionnaires
quand ils deviennent députés ou qu'il
devienne sénateurs le jour ils sont
battus pas de problème ils redeviennent
conseiller d'état inspecteur des
finances ambassadeurs c'est inacceptable
c'est inacceptable donc oui moi cette
étude je n'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'attention il ya urgence à réformer nos
institutions dans le champ de la
lisibilité de la simplicité de
l'efficacité pour que la décision
politique retrouve enfin du sens et
qu'elles changent réellement réellement
la vie quotidienne des français est ce
que cette recherche d'un homme fort par
les français interrogés ce que c'est bon
pour nicolas sarkozy par exemple en tout
cas c'est pas un homme faible
c'est une fille qui a du tempérament et
jeu pauvre un besoin de tempérament
politique on a besoin aujourd'hui d'une
personnalité qui s'engage avec sincérité
pour le bien public pour exemple
n'avaient rien donné c'est qui est
vraiment la volonté de changer les
choses de rentrer enfin dans la
modernité dans ce qu'est la société
française moi ce que je constate c'est
que nous responsables politiques nous
avons des années de retard sur la
société française nous sommes en
décalage par rapport à sur la pratique
des nouveaux instruments sur la pratique
des nouveaux outils de communication
d'internet ou autre nous avons du retard
sur nous et ce sur la conception la
société française nous avons dur qu'est
ce que vous allez faire comme nicolas
sarkozy va préciser ses intentions moi
je suis allé mais était candidat putatif
à la je n'ai jamais prononcé le mot de
candidats parce que je pense que c'est
un mot qui ne s'emploie qu'abonné si
l'on exclut et je poursuis mon chemin
avec une détermination totale à sa part
détermination totale pour vous pour vous
voyez bien que je défends ce tombeau
sera original oui je défends centre de
propositions que ne défend pas tout le
monde au sein de l'ump je les défendrai
avec une détermination et les défendre à
la primaire à l'ump nous verrons quelle
forme cela prendra mais en général quand
je m'engage dans un chemin je ne recule
pas
je parlais de manuel valls sur la sphère
dieudonné on l'accuse avoir agi par pur
calcul politique alain juppé au
contraire lui salue sa conviction
profonde à quelle est votre opinion je
fais aucun procès d'intention à manuel
valls ce qui compte pour moi ce sont les
résultats je crois que la bonne méthode
c'est de sanctionner systématiquement
les propos antisémites ou racistes de
dieudonné il fallait mettre le holà et
je me félicite qu'on ait mis le holà à
des propos qui ne sont pas compatibles
avec la république maintenant je
souhaite aussi qu'on ne fasse pas de
donner une victime médiatique et donc
simplement que la loi passe et
s'applique dieudonné doit des dizaines
de milliers d'euros au trésor public qui
les rembourse tout de suite pour le
citoyen comme vous comme moi comme ceux
qui nous écoutent qui ont une amende à
rembourser aux types de la sécurité
routière tout comme une infraction vous
pensez qu'on va les laisser tranquilles
on laissera jamais tranquille vous avez
vu cette histoire de cette femme qui
avait eu un trop perçu comme on dit au
titre des aides sociales elle vit avec
750 euros par mois on y rit les rebelles
en bourse que dû donner rembourse vite
et que le fisc soit efficace en la
matière a dit tout à l'heure que
l'interdiction du spectre des données
doit rester une exception et donc du
coup également l'inversion de la
jurisprudence par le conseil d'état doit
rester une exception oui moi je reste
sur la ligne que je défends depuis le
début majid al hawa d'essence et en ses
répliques s'il y a une déclaration
antisémite ou des propos racistes tenus
par des données dans un de ses
spectacles
doit-elle sanctionné immédiatement cette
sanction doit être suivi d'effets c'est
à dire qu'il doit payer les amendes
qu'il doit et puis il insiste aussi sur
un point qui me tient très à coeur je
crois qu'en matière d'éducation il faut
pas relâcher l'effort expliquer ce
qu'est la shoah ce que sont les actes
antisémites à quoi ça a conduit ce que
c'est que le racisme à quoi ça conduit
systématiquement c'est un combat que la
république doit livrer jusqu'au bout
c'est d'autant plus important que l'on
voit que maintenant qu'il a pris son
spectacle de dieudonné dans son théâtre
parisien il fait salle comble deux fois
dans la même soirée donc le public vient
en masse et applaudissent de quelqu'un
une victime médiatique elle en profite
toujours c'est pour ça soyons fermes
dans l'application de la loi mais n'en
faisons pas une victime médiatique en
interdisant systématiquement ses
spectacles
merci bruno la mère d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci perrine tarneaud
merci à tous vents soirée a très vite
tendance est très nette elle est très
claire elle nous mène aujourd'hui à le